you know James Corden announced that he
was leaving of course I was like okay
what is going to happen then Trevor Noah
announced that he was leaving The Daily
Show and I think what I ended up writing
a thing about was where is the female
where's the woman in late night yeah I
mean every our network has to ask
themselves that question at this point
because all these white guys are doing a
great job but they're not women you know
what I mean well let me tell you what I
found out what which was
um Gordon's show will become a panel
show and it even said in a lot of
articles that it's going to be
reminiscent of Chelsea Lately oh isn't
that interesting without me
[Applause]